Who am I you sure you want to know we
haven't even met yet what's missing how
did this asshole get out genetic super
spider builds drunken web I guess the
researchers are working on that one
because that's what they do when they
remove spiders instead of taking the
little glass box then let their in for
easy transport they scoop them out with
a mason jar and then go do research on
them Parker let's do it um thing
genetically enhance spider bit my hand I
know where your missing spider is you
think maybe I should get medic off at
helpful Science Museum screen gives tidy
rundown of the powers Peter Parker will
now receive also Sony product placement
in a Sony movie come on guys stop double
dipping guy who will soon become an
accidental supervillain conveniently
already working on super villainy things
prior to the transformation violence
aggression and insanity you diagnosed
insanity in a rat Norman the general
gave the go-ahead to quest aerospace to
build a prototype of their exoskeleton
design because that's what we normally
do in situations like this tell you
exactly where your money is going if you
fail and who you can get revenge on
later I'm already on my ass mate when
the plants senior electrician is laid
off after after 35 years what else would
you call it holy clunky exposition
Batman funhouse mirror Tobey Maguire guy
who will soon become an accidental
superhero conveniently already making
drawings and doodles of superhero he
thinks large alarming spider bite was
not on Peters right hand when he came
home
conveniently disguised so that his aunt
uncle couldn't see it I guess also these
symptoms waited all day to manifest
until Peter got home goodbye genetic
convenient audio flashback handholds the
audience through a complicated fact that
Peters bite from a super spider is
affecting him you know Norman Osborn may
be a genius but he's still like what
fifty years behind Stanley Tucci
scientist from Captain America in the
area of Super Soldier Serum research but
let me reschedule with a proper medical
staff in a volunteer I mean if you just
give me two weeks it takes two weeks to
get that kind of staff that's just long
enough to be pointless scientists
running out of time and funding test his
theories on himself cliche wait was that
one of the abilities the helpful screen
told us about as I see amazing vision on
this list but I guess you can't have
superhero with glasses or contacts that
would just be stupid stocking there's no
black Mustang in front of this bus in
this shot but in the next shot somehow
one arrives out of the bus dr. Strom is
dead they found his body this morning in
the lab unfortunately billion dollar
defense contractor Oscorp has no cameras
or sight sign in security features to
determine who might have been at the lab
at the time of dr. Strom's death Mary
Jane is in some kind of danger cliche
Mary Jane just happens to slip right in
front of Peter so we can see some of his
new abilities also everything that lands
on this tray just sticks there without
bouncing or obeying any of the laws of
motion because spider powers can also
change scientific principles nobody
fuckin notices this all the authorities
in this school are all outside smoking
right now apparently a for Peter punches
flashed the crowd circle is completely
closed in around him but when he punches
him flash goes flying there's an
instantaneous large gap for him to fly
through but in all honesty Harry and MJ
should be smashed like bowling pins
rubber Peter Sony saved approximately
two thousand dollars by reusing the same
POV shot over the laundry alley twice
within seven seconds nobody notices this
amateur wrestling ad offers the right
amount of money that Peter needs to buy
his Dakar Peter Webb's the dr. pepper
can and then the lamp and then there's a
knock on the door hello Aunt May and now
there's webs all over the fucking place
for some reason and they should totally
been able to see all these webs right
here
also that lamp he just destroyed is back
on the show somehow you start fights at
school I don't start that fight did
Peter get in trouble for that fight I
don't recall any teachers or authority
figures within a 10-mile radius of that
fight I guess all that happened off
screen but on screen no one gave it and
I know I'm not your father then stop
pretending to be you're not my father
cliche shady wrestling league only uses
verbal consent instead of actual legal
signed consent that's a cute outfit did
your husband give it to him that's
racist
Jesus really they actually want to
murder people with these things I would
also point out that this wrestling
bigwig guys should totally remember and
recognize Peter once Spiderman hits the
news but again they didn't take his
signature or even his name so Robert
decides the amateur wrestling operation
that's where I'll make my score what the
hell's the matter with you let him go
cop reprimand citizen for not doing cops
job go petty thief randomly shoots and
kills Uncle Ben out of all the people in
New York City just a question are there
any superhero movies where the hero's
parents or guardians don't die car crash
head on into a steel gate does nothing
to hurt the driver the robber lost his
gun here that's why he pulled out the
stupid knife but then when Peter kicks
him he suddenly has a gun again also
this must have surprised him too because
he doesn't even use it on spider-man
with a clear shot the police who were
right on this Chris tail when he arrived
at the Savannah Building take forever to
find him allowing Peter to have his
revenge
Peter remembers this wrong bullsquid
pipe causes thief to trip and fall
through windows so that morally
spider-man gets his vengeance but didn't
straight-up kill a guy
the NYPD called on a cop boat to help
take down one asshole nobody bothered to
call Aunt May during all this her father
got to place in New York so we're all
set this for odd choice of words aren't
you already in New York or are you doing
that Martin Scorsese thing in quiz show
we're Queens is not New York unwanted
touch in this shot but not so
touchy-feely in the next shot this
article copy pastes eight lines of the
story from the left column to the right
because no one at Sony had time to write
more than a total of 15 lines for the
fake news article also Shawn young
wasn't it John Young in the last article
NYPD fired their spokesperson over this
spider-man damn
Thanks and I don't like an average
everyday YouTube commenter he's leaving
notes now what is the Iron Monkey
we sold out for printings dude trying to
convince obvious bottom line motivated
guy the front page story is good waits
until the very end to drop his best
piece of evidence also we and the
audience get to spend a few more seconds
in the ADHD funhouse that is Jay jonah
Jameson's newspaper office even though
Mary Jane left the diner quite a while
ago and was out of sight her asshole
boss somehow expected to see her
standing out here and give this
embarrassing ultimatum in front of Peter
ideal to me oh she is Norman plays the
pronoun game so that Peter has to ask
who the hell he's talking about
Peter rips away his identity with a
series of photographs so good so varied
and so up-close and personal that even a
child would know that only spider-man
himself could have taken them jeez a
movie with this much CGI can't bother to
remove the ing lion logos from the
Oscorp building after the world unity
festival world unity festival see this
is what happens when you book a music
act for your movie immediately after
their debut single but before actually
waiting to see if they'll be a
long-lasting star or just fade back into
musical obscurity I mean honestly at
this point Macy Gray is probably more
well known for being in this movie than
for that trying to say goodbye and I
choke song right Peter starts taking
pictures for no reason at all and
somehow lands on Harry and Mary Jane
then Harry spots Peter in the crown
below that's some simple bullet right
there I know he's getting revenge on the
Oscorp people but is he so mad that
he'll potentially bomb his son too Mary
Jane is in some kind of danger cliche
what's the bigger sin the terrible aim
of the high-tech next-gen glider and its
pilot or the fact that no random
citizens were harmed during this machine
gun chase subway bandits strike again
where was Spiderman during that you
should know I'm crazy Bob it's just you
know he never made a move bro code
violation in all 50 states fucker
I guess Peter spidey sense just took a
day off didn't it who's the photographer
take some pictures of spider-man
so Peter gets money for taking pictures
of spider-man but he's not credited in
the paper for taking them an amazing
creature spider-man geez we're only in
the first movie and the villain is
already trying to team up with someone
or we could destroy caused the deaths of
countless innocence and selfish battle
again and again and again until we're
both dead or you could just kill
spider-man now Green Goblin allows time
for spider-man to think about teaming up
rather than demanding an answer now
which would make the decision to kill
him a lot easier should he say no faith
I needed acting lessons urge to make
snarky remark so strong right now 1975
New York City decides to assault Mary
Jane Mary Jane is in some kind of danger
cliche whoa this suddenly turned into
the best movie ever seriously no time
for the mask at all also wait a minute
he clearly had the mask on when he was
on the rooftops a minute ago I guess he
lost it masks are always just slipping
off people's faces these days look maybe
it's an alley so dark that you can't see
faces maybe it's not all I know is there
appear to be a lot of street lamps on
around here and MJ should totally see
Peter's face right now and he managed to
put that mask on more quickly than he
lost it you have a knack for getting in
trouble
Mary Jane doesn't recognize spider-man's
obvious Peter Parker voice scenes is not
contain an upside-down lap dance okay so
what were the responsible adults who
were watching the baby doing when the
building caught fire special effects are
special did this need to be a surprise
why didn't Green Goblin just fly around
the city and throw a bomb or two to draw
spider-man out also this must be the
only thing happening in New York City
right now Green Goblin took a risk that
the subway bandits wouldn't be striking
again at this hour it's you who's out
gobby out of your mind
wrong sir oh my god what the hell is
this Green Goblin threw a bomb earlier
that turned people into skeletons not to
mention those other really effective
just plain exploding bombs he threw
before that but now in a cramped space
goblin throws this bull look I'm sorry
Peter should have caught the blood drop
and probably could have done it too does
he need both hands and both feet to
stick to the ceiling
probably not as it is the blood drops to
the floor Norman here's it now we're
supposed to swallow the fact that Peter
ran across the ceiling out the window
and underneath the balcony without
making one noise Green Goblin failed to
remove spider-man's mask earlier in the
film with the kidnapped him so that we
could enjoy the scene of realization
finally kicking in and also to add about
20 minutes to the total runtime Aunt May
says just enough before Peter is thrown
out to give him all the info he needs
you're not Superman you know DC Comics
Mary Jane is in some kind of danger
cliche that
I the woman you love suffers a little
children we interrupt the spider-man
movie to bring you the hero has to
choose moment from Batman Forever most
convenient barge in the history of
barges while that took forever
also Green Goblin wastes everyone's time
including the audience's by not having
some bombs ready for this scenario oh
boat already she's not spider-man right
someone has amazing timing and aim to
hit the Goblin underneath the bridge
like this are you mess with one of us
you mess with all of us New Yorkers band
together in a crisis cliche and finally
oh okay one more bomb right one more
bomb oh you're gonna monologue now
aren't spider-man suddenly shows
strength that he did not show through
this entire fight because Green Goblin
threatened MJ villains arm thrust
through the rubble and or nuclear waste
cliche as we watch goblin summon his
glider into this mess I start wondering
where is that sleeping potion he used
earlier that was a good weapon
Godspeed spider-man dude this is like
the millionth time you've opened your
mouth and let spider-man live even
though goblins glider was clearly shown
to have been within inches of his face
he's still allowed to say Oh for laughs
before the glider warps back into the
screen Norman Osborn just happens to get
buried in the same cemetery as Ben
Parker right because you recognize the
kiss but not the voice that completely
makes sense
computer salesman computer engineer
computer analyst my lord even the
computers need analysts these days oh
they have the internet on computers now
Tommy how's the peeping Tommy I was a
big thing
Donald Redbury shot himself in 1980
Charles boy a 1978 pills again Charles
Butterworth 1946 I think in a car
supposedly it was an accident but you
know he was distraught Dorothy Dandridge
pills 1965 I was a Decker 1968 he hung
himself he wrote a suicide note in
lipstick on the stomach huh is the world
masters my friend you don't have any
friends nobody likes you how strange
there's nobody here
a bit of a slob is nee all brilliant men
are